llega el momento de nuestra revista de
prensa en directo América con Rosa Pérez
más deu Rosa Buen día para usted Buenos
días Ángela Pues bien Vamos a comenzar
hablando de la portada de liberación con
el que seguramente el tema del día que
dibuja un macron en busca de la salida a
una crisis múltiple que sigue y sigue
creciendo exactamente en la portada de
este periódico francés vemos la imagen
de macron muy aislado no con el título
crisis social y política violencia por
dónde es la salida y cómo subtítulo la
siguiente reflexión los sindicatos
mantienen Este martes la presión con una
décima jornada de movilizaciones contra
la reforma de las pensiones debilitado
El Ejecutivo multiplica las reuniones
para salir de un lodazal que el mismo ha
contribuido a crear y dos matices
respecto a estas palabras por un lado
que cuando dice este medio Liberación
que El Ejecutivo multiplica las
reuniones Cabe destacar que son
reuniones entre el propio ejecutivo que
el gobierno ha rechazado de hecho así lo
ha expresado portavoces del ejecutivo
francés reunirse Con el líder del
principal sindicato no que buscaba una
mediación para salir un poco de esta
encrucijada por otro lado recordemos
también que sí esta es la décima jornada
de protestas convocada oficialmente por
los sindicatos pero que la indignación
estalló después de que el gobierno
utilizara el artículo 49.3 para aprobar
sin votación en la asamblea nacional
está impopular reforma de las pensiones
y que desde ese día desde en las 16 de
marzo si no estoy equivocada las
manifestaciones se multiplicaron de
forma espontánea bien en todo caso esto
pues ocupa no las portadas a francesas
claro y los sindicatos cada vez hacen
más presión ahora están apelando a los
métodos de la fuerza pública que
denuncian como violentos o como de uso
excesivo de la fuerza exactamente y el
medio lomont titula en su portada en
papel macron intenta apaciguar la
situación pero
suceder nada no en relación a este
bloqueo de momento a reunirse con los
sindicatos Pero además
lemont señala que varias organizaciones
como ha sido el caso del Consejo de
Europa también del relator de Naciones
Unidas de reporteros se hacen fronteras
o de la liga francesa de los derechos
humanos han señalado preocupación por el
uso excesivo de la fuerza policial y de
hecho también en la portavoz francés
Olivia eran ha señalado que el gobierno
no el estado ostenta el muro de
protección contra la violencia ilegítima
y es que recordemos que un poco la
estrategia retórica del gobierno francés
para deslegitimar el movimiento contra
la reforma de las pensiones ha sido
poner mucho el foco en la violencia en
las protestas que macron de hecho en una
entrevista que dio la semana pasada con
las dos principales cadenas de
televisión a francesas llegó a comparar
el movimiento con el asalto al Capitolio
bien Además este de semana ha habido una
protesta ecologista no que no tiene que
ver necesariamente con la reivindicación
contra la reforma de las pensiones pero
sí digamos que se enmarca en el mismo
contexto de descontento con el gobierno
de macron una protesta que ha sido
reprimida con un alto uso de las
granadas de
reglamento de como de dispersión que ha
causado heridos graves bien la situación
es un poco digamos complicada ahora
mismo para el presidente Manuel macron
presidente que no da su brazo a torcer
pero no sucedió así en Israel donde
Benjamín netanyahu tuvo que ponerle
pausa a su reforma judicial y hay mucho
más sobre la presión ejercida contra el
Primer Ministro de lo que se ve digamos
en los titulares exactamente y así lo
muestra el New York Times que titula
cómo ha sido digamos la campaña de
presión de la Administración
estadounidense hacia el gobierno israelí
David firma un artículo que explica las
48 horas antes de que natanyahu su plan
de reforma judicial el presidente Joe
biden y sus consejeros bombardearon al
gobierno israelí con advertencias de que
la imagen de Israel como única
democracia del medio oriente estaba en
juego y quisiera que nos detengara nos
detuviéramos un momento en esto de
Israel como única democracia de medio
oriente porque esta calificativo
Precisamente es bastante cuestionado no
y es que varias organizaciones que no
están tampoco a favor de la Reforma pero
también son críticas con el movimiento
señalan que en este movimiento tampoco
se reivindica la situación de los
palestinos no y es que gobiernos de
varios colores han permitido la
ampliación de los asentamientos de la
ocupación ilegal de territorios
palestinos y también del avance y la
discriminación entre judíos y no judíos
en todo caso en el discurso mains no de
Estados Unidos señala esto que Israel es
la única democracia de medio oriente sin
embargo la Casa Blanca señaló que ya fue
un límite que Estados Unidos no digamos
a permitir sobrepasar esta reforma
judicial y que de hecho fue una movida
bastante inusual el decir públicamente
que Joe biden había intentado de influir
en el gobierno de Benjamín netanyahu que
como decíamos finalmente pasó esta
protesta y Estados Unidos lo analiza de
dos formas por un lado señala que
netaría jucalpuló mal no está reforma y
por otro lado que antes ante sus aliados
a más extremistas dijo que no se puede
permitir perder en la vínculo de Alianza
con Washington ante una posible nueva
crisis con Irán lo decía hoy en una
publicación de redes nuestra
corresponsal en Israel y territorios
palestinos una protesta que nunca
veremos tan fuerte por la causa
Palestina gracias a usted Rosa y nos
vemos mañana hasta mañana